Transcriber: Rasha Nasser
المدقّق: Bashar Al-Thawabta
(موسيقى)
السلام عليكم
أنا اسمي جنى وعمري ٩ سنوات
سأحكي لكم قصة يلقبوني فيها بـ أخر العنقود
سكر معقود، دلوعة بابا وحبيبته
(مثل شامي)
ولكن في يوم استيقظت على صوت عالي،
الجميع يبكي
وحينما سألتهم ماذا حصل؟
لم يجيب احدًا واستمروا بالبكاء
وقالوا يجب ان نذهب لأبينا
لأن امرًا ما قد اصابه
في الأول، قالت والدتي سأذهب لوحدي، ولكن
الذي اتصل بنا رفض ذلك وقال الكل يأتي هناك
ولكن الذي اتصل بنا رفض ذلك
وقال الكل يأتي هناك
وأنا في الطريق كنت خايفه كثيرًا عليه
ولكن طمئنت نفسي وحدثتها بأن
ما اصابه الآن قد حدث مثله بالماضي
التي دخل فيها العناية المركزة
ولكن عاد لنا بحمد الله.
أنتم تعلمون حينما ذهبت هناك
الجميع قالوا لي ان والدك توفى
ولكن حينما دخلت ورأيته
كان نائمًا فقط
انتم تعلمون اني مريت بهذا الإمتحان
بعدة شعور
أول شعور هو الصدمة
أن انكر ماهو حقيقي أمامي
وكنت بالفعل مصدومه
والشعور الثاني هو الحزن
وأنا احدث نفسي حزينةً
ان ذلك لن يحصل تمامًا
والشعور الثالث هو الشوق
أن اتمنى ان يعود بي الزمن للوراء
وأرى فيها ابي مره اخرى
وأهم وأخر امر هو التقبل
وهي اني تقبلت كل امر
بمساعدة اخواتي وامي
وامي واخواتي ساعدوني بأمور كثيره
وايضًا كانوا ينصحوني بأن اظهر مشاعري
ان اخاف واحزن وابكي
كانوا دائمًا بجانبي يساندوني
أنتم تعلمون اني ايضًا مررت
أنا وعائلتي وامي فكرنا
كيف نتصدق لأبينا بحسنات تدخله الجنة
أنا رفعت يدي وقلت
سألبسه تاج الكرامة
لو حفظت القرآن كاملًا إن شاء الله
سألبس والدي تاج الكرامة
لو حفظت القرآن كاملًا
(تصفيق)
وهأنذي سجلت في مساقين بحفظ القرآن
الأول جزء تبارك والثاني جزء عمّ
وقد صنعت علاقات كثيره
وانتم تعلمون بماذا مررت ايضًا
بهذا الإختبار؟
لقد تعلمت من هذا الإختبار امرًا
وهو كمثل الشجرة
وجذور الشجره كالعائله الصغيره
هي مثلا ابي وامي واخواتي
والعائله الأكبر سنًا هي الأغصان
وهي خالتي وعمتي وعمي
واما عن الأوراق، فهي الجزء الثالث
وأما عن الأوراق، فهي الجزء الثالث
وهي الأصدقاء
نحن لا نستطيع العيش من دونهم
يجب ان نعيش بهم جميعًا
ولكن الجزء الاهم منهم، هو الجذور
الذين يثبتون في الارض معنا دائمًا
وبجانبنا دائمًا
انا أدعي لوالدي ولو سمحتم ادعوا له ايضًا
(تصفيق)
(موسيقى)